A lighthouse appears and a storm shelter door
opens. A nanny emerges from the shelter.
Storms'a coming.
There's a lot for the opening in the rocks.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I think I missed some
of those words.
Oh, I was trying a Scottish dialect.
Uh huh.
Because the nanny's...
The nanny refers to a childhood in Aberdeen.
Right...
Or not...
No, no, no.
No, no, no. It's okay to try things. Let's
just go again.
A nanny emerges from the shelter.
Storm's coming.
Don't think it's a night for roaming on the
rocks.
French-Canadian. Because it's up in the
Maritimes there.
So a lot of French.
I'm sorry. It's- this is my process.
It's just how I find the nanny's voice.
You know what? Maybe we try slightly more how
you talk.
A nanny emerges from the shelter.
Storm's coming.
Don't think it's a night for roaming on the
rocks.
I don't go roaming anywhere.
It's you.
Oh, my God. It's me. Oh, I'm so sorry. Oh,
I'm sorry. It's me, isn't it?
It's you.
It's your line. Yes.